thank you
good morning good afternoon bonjour
thank you for joining us
today we're here to talk to you about
health canada's authorization of
medicago's kobe fins covid19 vaccine for
adults 18 to 64 years of age this is the
first authorized covid19 vaccine
developed by a canadian company
after an in-depth review of the evidence
we've determined that this vaccine meets
the department's stringent safety
efficacy and quality requirements
the medical vaccine is the sixth coven
19 vaccine authorized by health canada
and as with the other approved vaccines
canadians can be confident that health
canada conducted a thorough review to
ensure the vaccine is manufactured to
high quality standards and that the
scientific data available to support the
safety and the efficacy of the vaccine
meet the canadian standards
detailed information on health canada's
review is available on the covid19
vaccines and treatment portal
at covid
vaccine.canada.ca
medical vaccine is a plant-backed
plant-based vaccine called a virus-like
particle vaccine
the active ingredient of the vaccine
consists of particles that mimic the
spike protein of the virus that causes
copin 19. the virus-like particles are
grown in plants that are similar to
tobacco plants which can produce large
amounts of the virus particles in a
short period of time
once these particles are injected into
the body they trigger the immune system
to produce antibodies against the virus
these virus-like particles mimic the
natural structure of the virus without
its genetic material which makes a
person's immune system able to recognize
the particles without causing infection
so through this process the body can
mount a strong immune response against
the protein without exposure to the
entire virus that causes covid19 and
with as with all other covid19 vaccines
it is not possible to catch coca-19 from
this vaccine
there are other vaccines that use
virus-like particles such as those for
hpv or human papillomavirus and
hepatitis b
but these are not manufactured using
plants
so covifens is the first vaccine
authorized globally that uses a plant as
the host to manufacture these virus-like
particles
in clinical trials of about 30 000
people the medical vaccine was found to
be 71 percent effective against
symptomatic covid19
it was also 100 effective against severe
disease caused by copit19
this is when the vaccine is given
according to the authorized dosing
regimen that is two doses 21 days apart
clinical trials were conducted while
there were various variants in
circulation including the alpha gamma
lambda lambda delta and mu variants
the data suggests efficacy against all
of these variants
preliminary laboratory data also shows
that the vaccine produces neutralizing
antibodies against the omicron variant
as a term and condition associated with
the authorization medical is required to
provide data regarding protection
against current and emerging variants of
concern as soon as it's available
since the phase 3 vaccine clinical
trials were conducted at a time where a
large proportion of older people were
already vaccinated there was a limited
number of participants above the age of
65 in the trials
medical is currently gathering data on
older individuals and is also studying
the use of the vaccine as a booster dose
with respect to safety common side
effects with this vaccine include pain
and tenderness at the injection site
headache muscle pain fever and chills
the majority of these adverse reactions
and clinical trials were mild to
moderate in severity and resolved within
a few days also these side effects are
typical with most vaccines
there were no differences in the
percentage of serious adverse events
reported in the vaccine group and the
placebo group or the group that did not
get the vaccine
summaries of this information can be
found on the health canada website and
today health canada has published
multiple documents on the covid19
vaccines and treatments portal related
to this approval
and those include a high level summary
of the evidence we reviewed the canadian
product monograph
product labels as well as the terms and
conditions associated with the
authorization
so with six vaccines currently
authorized health canada and the public
health agency of canada are continuing
to actively monitor their safety in the
real world
we monitor for any adverse events or
side effects in collaboration with the
provinces and territories international
partners as well as the manufacturers
and as with all vaccines we will take
action if any safety issues are
identified ongoing reporting of any
potential side effects is critical to
supporting this monitoring and canadians
can report any possible side effects to
their healthcare professionals
today's authorization provides an
additional option to fight this pandemic
it has been almost two years since the
pandemic began and we are all eager to
get back to regular life as much as as
quickly as possible
on top of continuing to follow public
health guidelines i urge everyone to
continue to do their part and get
vaccinated
it's never too late to get your first
second or third dose thank you merci
bonjour mercedes
a
foreign
is
um
foreign
is
again
is
is
labels
is
foreign
[Music]
is
thank you we'll move to questions uh if
you have a question please your ra raise
your hand on the zoom platform so i can
acknowledge uh we'll begin with
mac maxine denis from tevye
canada
rather than other vaccines that we have
in our possessions
uh
worldwide
uh
is
thank you we'll move to jamie morocco
global news
hi all thank you for taking my question
i'm just going to first ask that you uh
repeat repeat the
previous question about sending the
vaccines to developing nations perhaps
to kovacs in english if possible and
then i'll go to my question
it's a doctor new uh
between dr bakuma and myself uh
certainly canada is committed to to the
global effort to be able to uh supply
vaccines across the world and i think
we've committed to the equivalent i
think over 200 million uh doses uh two
of two kovacs in the in the
international effort
certainly uh the medical this new
vaccine that's been approved here in
canada uh would be part of of that that
contribution but i guess to to the
question as to where it sits you know is
there a hierarchy or prioritization uh
we can't speak to that obviously it's in
the mix along with all of the other
vaccines that are currently approved in
canada as well so that that's all we can
say at this point thank you
okay thank you so much uh my question is
um
we've seen from nasi that they've
consistently recommended an mrna vaccine
over the other types of vaccine is that
still the case um with this plant-based
technology still the recommendation is
to go with an mrna vaccine
it's dr nu i could i could start off but
certainly uh our our nasi uh committee
is looking actively they're they're
looking at the same data that obviously
our health canada regulators uh have
received and they'll they're they'll be
making a statement i think i anticipate
in the next
uh a couple of weeks but at this point
it's not for me to speculate as to what
they will indicate certainly the data is
there and they're going to analyze that
uh
but you're right uh to to date with
respect to the vaccines that are
currently available in canada they have
indicated a sort of a preference for the
mrna uh vaccines uh both from sort of a
effectiveness point of view but also
because of the well-known safety profile
but uh it remains to be seen uh when
they come up with their their their
steam bidding recommendations with
respect to the medical vaccine
okay i have other callers but no hands
raised is that it for questions then
please raise your hand i'll give it a
few more seconds here
okay there doesn't appear to be any more
questions so i guess that concludes this
this morning thank you very much doctors
thank you
lexi thank you